SHANE GLASS: Hi.
My name's Shane Glass, and
I'm the program manager
for Google Cloud's
public datasets program.
And I'm here today to talk to
you about the public datasets
we have available in BigQuery
and Google Cloud Storage,
as well as how they can
support your workloads.
And don't worry-- there's
a fun demo at the end, too.
Now, the mission of our
public dataset program
is quite simply to maximize the
availability and accessibility
of high-value, high-demand
public data assets
through Google Cloud.
And we do this because
we fundamentally
believe that it makes
life a little bit easier
for our users.
We currently have more than 130
datasets in our public dataset
program, and these datasets
are onboarded and maintained
by Googlers with provider
input and guidance.
You can see here a sample
of our data providers,
including NOAA, the US Census
Bureau, the United Nations
Statistics Division,
the Federal Elections
Commission, and others.
We're constantly
adding new datasets.
And here are just three examples
of recently-added, unstructured
datasets, all coming from
NOAA-- the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration.
They include a high-resolution
rapid refresh weather model,
the new GOES-16 satellite
imagery, and NOAA's National
Water Model that
provides stream flow
information across the
continental United States.
We also have datasets in
BigQuery, including the GitHub
repository; the NOAA
Global Surface Summary
of the Day, that provides
meteorological observations
going back to 1900; and
the Ethereum blockchain,
along with six other
cryptocurrencies.
But don't just take
my word for it.
Let's see a demo
specifically looking
at how you can use some
of our geospatial datasets
to support your workflows.
So let's look at a
demonstration that tells you
how many lightning
strikes there were
across the continental
United States in 2018,
thanks to the lightning data
we have available from NOAA.
You can see here a query
that runs real quickly,
and I'll give you a
concatenation and a little bit
cleaner format so
that it's easier
to visualize this
data in Data Studio.
So I'll click Run down
here, and a little
like they do in
the cooking shows,
I already have it finished.
You can see here the number
of lightning strikes,
with a center point
of a 1/10 degree
by 1/10 degree tile
that aggregates
the strikes across the US.
We'll take a look in
Data Studio and see
what we notice trend-wise.
We'll flip over to our
cooking show finished version,
and you can see here
the aggregated number
of lightning strikes
across the year on average.
But this doesn't
really tell us much,
as it's hard to see the
specific data points.
So let's zoom in using the Zoom
Area function in Data Studio,
and we'll zoom in to
the United States.
And this is primarily
where the data comes from.
Now, I had originally
expected Florida
to have the most
lightning strikes per day,
but as you can see,
what really stands out
on this map is the collection
of data here in Oklahoma.
Now I'm curious, and I
want to dig in further.
And how can you use public
datasets to do that?
Now, we can use the geospatial
capabilities-- or GIS--
that are built into
BigQuery, and this
helps BigQuery understand
the geospatial relationship
between datasets.
Now, this particular query
has a little pre-processing
done under the hood, but
we're hopeful to make
that unnecessary here
in the near future.
For now, we'll
take the shortcut.
And so this query
gives us the return
of a polygon for each
tile, as well as the number
of lightning strikes by day.
But let's say we
wanted to look at that
in a more visual format.
Well, I'd come over to BigQuery
GeoViz, the geovisualization
capability available for free.
I could come down here and run
the same query, see my results,
and define which
column is our geometry.
And from there, I give a
style that best fits our data.
In this case, I've given
an interval for the number
of strikes and location.
And I can tell you, as a
former Oklahoma resident,
this makes a lot of sense to me.
The areas of Oklahoma that
are notorious for the storms
are also seeing the greatest
number of lightning strikes.
But this is pretty broad.
These are 1/10 of a degree
by 1/10 of a degree tiles
across the state.
Well, what does
that actually mean?
No one measures the world
in 10th of degree tiles.
Instead, we define the
world by boundaries--
in most cases, the US political
and statistical boundaries,
such as either counties
or census tracts.
In this case, let's take a
look at one of the 10 boundary
datasets we have
available in BigQuery
through the public
dataset program
that defines the space
around each of these borders.
In this case, we'll
start with counties,
since that's a pretty
popular one in Oklahoma.
We run a pretty similar
query, except this time,
we'll take a little
shortcut so that I only
have to remember the state name
as opposed to the state FIPS
code.
And again, we'll
run our results,
and we'll see that counties this
time is the geometric column.
And again, we can
run our visualization
and add style that meets
the needs of our dataset.
And one of the nice features
about BigQuery GeoViz
is it allows me to go in and
click on an individual county
and see what the
exact outputs were.
And we can see
here, for example,
that Oklahoma County has about
300 lightning strikes per day.
And this pretty closely
lines up with what
we saw from the other map,
except on a more understandable
boundary.
What if we want to look at
something more granular,
though--
say, for instance, ZIP codes?
Again, we'll take
the same dataset,
but this time we'll define it
by the spaces of ZIP codes--
or ZIP code tabulation
areas, in this case--
and we'll run that through.
And that gives you a
better idea of maybe
what ZIP code you want
to avoid, assuming you
don't like lightning strikes.
We'll go through
the same process,
and we'll define the same style.
This time, let's use a
different method of defining
that data-driven column.
So let's use a
linear extrapolation.
We'll give it a low of 27--
as you can see, the
minimum down here--
and then we'll go
up by 100 from here.
So 120, 220, 320, and so on.
And I'll want to get
over my max of 499.
I'll quickly set the
colors down here,
and I can scroll through
some different options
to find one that
suits my palette.
In this case, I
want to do something
pretty similar to the one
I used in the counties.
And you can see
here again, there's
a dark concentration here
around Oklahoma City.
But this time, I can drill
down to a more granular level
and see which ZIP codes might
make it the most likely for me
to see some lightning
strikes in my backyard.
So this is just one
example of what can
be done with public datasets.
If you're interested in
learning more, and figuring out
how you can join public datasets
with your private datasets,
I encourage you to check
out GCP Marketplace
and click on Datasets
on the left-hand side.
There, you can learn
more about datasets
and get started
in BigQuery today.